[موسيقى]
اليوم الاول من الغزو الروسيه لاوكرانيا
لم يتركوا لنا اي خيار روسيا استخدمت كل
وسائل الاعتداء
المعدات التي تمر من هنا هي معدات روسيه
[تصفيق]
تتطاير حول
ومن قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لدعم
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه الصينيه تقول باننا نراقب الوضع
في اوكرانيا عن كثب عبد الجواده رشد ومن
كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
اخر التحديثات في موسكو نحو 200 نقطه
عسكريه ستكون العربيه شاهده على مناورات
هذه محطه المياه الخاصه بمدينه جرينجا هذا
الامس كنا نشير الى 58 موقعا تم اسعافهم
طفلان وسته بالغين
هذه التغطيه المتواصله من العربيه
لمحاولات انقاذ الطفل ريان
[موسيقى]
تحدث
والدفاعل في العربيه
من الامطار بعمليه يمكن الدورات الاخيره
امام الانتظار صاحبها حزن كبير مع اعلان
وفاه ريان
[موسيقى]
رسمي عن وفاه ملكه بريطانيا اليزابيث
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
الى هذه التغطيه المستمره لليوم الذي يوصف
باليوم التاريخي اليوم طوت لندن صفحه من
تاريخها عيون العالم كلها الان على لندن
في اكبر حدث
دبلوماسي اكبر حدث امني بوجود قاده من حول
العالم رؤساء ملوك امراء لحضور جنازه
الملكه اليزابيث
مليون شخص توافدوا على هذا المكان جنازه
ستشهد اكبر عمليه امنيه في بريطانيا هل
كانت كل صفحات الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
مضيئه ام لا
[موسيقى]
المعهد الامريكي يقول ان زلزالا بقوه ثمان
درجات يضرب جنوب تركيا
وقع زلزال في منطقه
السبع درجات هذه التغطيه مستمره على شاشه
العربيه وصور مختلفه لاثار الدمار ومن
اكثر من منطقه نواصل معكم هذه التغطيه
المباشره والمستمره من استديوهات العربيه
هنا في الرياض دمار كامل في هذه المدينه
الان
غير قادرين على انقاذ ضحايا الزلزال
قفز عدد قتل الزلزال المدمر وسط ظروف صعبه
جدا للطعام وللمنامه ومع دخولنا اليوم
الرابع
طبعا مشاهد مؤلمه نتيجه هذا الزلزال
التركيه تحدث الارقام